hello there today we're going to look at
the dimpled manifold model of
adversarial examples
in machine learning by adi shamir odalia
melamed
and oriel ben shmuel this paper on a
high level proposes a new way of
looking at the phenomenon of adversarial
examples in machine learning
specifically in
deep learning and they proposed this
model called the dimpled manifold model
essentially arguing that classifiers put
their decision
boundaries right next to the manifold of
data
while only slightly sort of curving it
around the data
like this now the data manifold being
low dimensional this results in a
situation where you can
cross the decision boundary really
easily
if you simply go perpendicular to the
data manifold which also is
perpendicular to the decision boundary
and if because it's just such a small
dimple there
uh the decision boundary is pretty close
and
that's how you end up with adversarial
examples that are super
easy to get so it's not a new attack a
new
defense anything like this it's simply a
mental framework of explaining why
adversarial examples
exist on a high level they have some
conceptual thought experiments
uh they have um some explanations and
some real world
experiments now i personally
don't think that this is entirely it's
not necessarily
incorrect but i don't think that this is
really useful
to think in this way and i'm gonna
explain why
in general my opinion of this is it
doesn't really add anything
and i think it explains less
than the models we already had um
yeah so that's that's my opinion i'm
gonna get to it specifically also
the experiments they propose i think
that
there is a big occam's razor failure
right there
but as i said we're gonna get to all of
this and go through the paper
and i want you to make up your own mind
even though i'm going to try to bias you
so uh yeah this is this is not a neutral
channel in case you haven't noticed
all right so if you you know like
content or if you dislike it tell me in
the comments tell me
what you think of the paper whether it
makes sense whether it doesn't make
sense
and so on i'd be very interested to see
what you have to say
uh yeah i read the comments so please
they say the extreme fragility of deep
neural networks when presented with tiny
perturbations
okay this starts out how every single
adversarial example's paper
always starts out saying okay deep
neural networks are extremely fragile
there's this phenomenon
of adversarial examples now if you don't
know what adversarial examples are
really briefly essentially what this is
it's a phenomenon where you take an
image
like the thing here on the left uh the
neural network thinks it's a plane with
a very high probability
and you change it to this thing right
here which
you as a human can't even tell it's
different however the neural network
will think that this is now a bird
with very high probability and the this
is the change that you made
uh it's magnified for you to see
it kind of looks like random noise but
it's a very particular noise
that makes the neural network think it's
something different and
this is just it's tiny in the in its
norm right so you don't see a difference
now bird here is kind of close to plane
but you can change this into anything
literally anything you want you can
change this into banana
or uh i don't know dog or
any class you want using these
techniques so it's not about
being close it's really kind of a
separate phenomenon
so that's adversarial examples and many
frameworks have been
proposed in order to explain these
adversarial examples and they make a
they make a nice overview
right here um many had been proposed
over the last 18 last eight years that
dnns are too non-linear that they're too
linear that they were trained with
insufficient number of training examples
that are
just rare cases where they err that
images contain robust and non-robust
features
etc they say however none of these
vague qualitative ideas seem to provide
a simple intuitive explanations for the
existence and bizarre properties of
adversarial examples
so that is pretty harsh criticism
specifically
the first ones are kind of yeah but
specifically this last one that images
contain robust and non-robust features
which is sort of the leading
hypothesis right now of why adversarial
examples exist and what they are
and them here saying none of these can
none of these
vague qualitative ideas seem to provide
a simple
intuitive explanation for the existence
like let's see whether or not they're
gonna
do better okay so
um also in the abstract
they go on and they say okay they
introduced this new conceptual framework
which they call the dimpled manifold
model
which provides a simple explanation for
why adversarial examples exist
why their perturbations have such tiny
norms why these perturbations look like
random noise
and why a network which was
adversarially trained
with incorrectly labeled images can
still correctly classify
test images now this last part if you're
not familiar with the literature it
might
come to you a bit random this why
network which was adversarially trained
with incorrectly labeled images can
still
correctly classify test images
this is a famous experiment from the
group of alexander madri
where also this this hypothesis this one
the robust and non-robust feature comes
from
and any any attempt at explaining
adversarial examples after this paper
has to explain why that experiment makes
sense because it's kind of a
non-intuitive experiment and
we're gonna get to that as well but just
so you know that's why they write it in
the abstract
now i personally think they don't have a
good like this model here doesn't have a
good explanation for why that works
uh they're sort of hand-wavy trying
in any case so they say in
in the last part of the paper we
describe the results of numerous
experiments
which strongly support this new model
and in particular our assertion that
adversarial perturbations are roughly
perpendicular
to the low dimensional manifold which
contains all the training examples
okay also remember this experiment they
strongly support
what in particular the assertion that
adversarial perturbations are roughly
perpendicular
to the low dimensional manifold which
contains all the training
examples now remember this
that the experiments are supposed to
support
this particular claim because also that
is going to be important down the road
okay
so let's get into the dimpled manifold
model what is it
what do these authors propose and i'm
going to try as best as i can to
say what the authors are saying in the
paper
so they claim that there is an old
mental image of adversarial examples
and the old mental image is um
is here
it's uh they say we think
the old mental image is based on the
highly misleading 2d image on the left
side of
figure 1 and that's this thing
right here so the old mental image is
that there's
a there is a data space right this here
if you think of pic of images as data
points
this would be the pixel space right so
this is images with two pixels
right now in this conceptual framework
but you have to sort of think yourself
into higher dimension
so they claim the old mental images the
following you have sort of the data
distributed
somehow in this space the data being the
all the set of natural images or images
you consider
which is kind of these these subspace
these subgroups right here
there are a bunch of images right there
and there and also
there and there so these are images of
two different classes the red class and
the blue class
now they're distributed like this and
what is a classifier supposed to do
a classifier is supposed to put a
decision boundary between them and
that's what they
draw in here so this would be sort of a
reasonable decision boundary between the
two classes
right so now what do you do if you want
to create an adversarial examples well
necessarily
you have to start at an image of a class
this one maybe and you have to cross the
decision boundary right you want to
fool the classifier ergo necessarily by
definition you have to cross the
decision boundary so what do you do
the the easiest way to do this is to
sort of go
straight towards the decision boundary
which is approximately
in this direction right here and then
once you cross the decision boundary
you are done you're on the other side
you have created an adversarial
example provided of course that
the image still kind of looks like the
original image
okay so they say this has
this has many many problems here
they say the in this mental this mental
image adversarial examples are created
by moving the given images along the
green arrows towards
some kind of centroid of the nearest
training images with the opposite
label in which they mean this this thing
right here
so we would move the images towards the
other class towards the images of the
other class
and they say as stated for example by
ian goodfellow
in his lecture at this time i'm going to
cut this in
right here i've i've said that the same
perturbation can fool many different
models or the same perturbation can be
applied
to many different clean examples i've
also said that the subspace
of adversarial perturbations is only
about 50 dimensional
even if the input dimension is 3000
dimensional
so how is it that these subspaces
intersect
the reason is that the choice of the
subspace directions is not
completely random it's generally going
to be something like
pointing from one class centroid to
another class centroid
and if you look at that vector and
visualize it as an image it might not be
meaningful to a human
just because humans aren't very good at
imagining what class centroids look like
and we're really bad at imagining
differences between centroids
but there is more or less this
systematic effect
that causes different models to learn
similar linear functions
just because they're trying to solve the
same task
okay so it really appears like
goodfellow says
this thing right here however they claim
now they claim this doesn't make sense
so they claim that you should think
about adversarial examples in a
different way and this is their dimpled
manifold hypothesis
so what is their dimpled manifold
hypothesis they say
what you have to do is you have to think
about the data manifold
in the higher dimensional space that
they have the higher dimensional input
space so in this case
they consider instead of here this 2d
landscape they consider
the 3d landscape so this would be the
pixel space right now we consider
three pixel images and
the data is embedded in a low
dimensional manifold
in this higher space so because
if you think about all combinations of
pixels that are possible
so not all of them are natural images in
fact
only very few of the possible
combinations of pixels
are natural images or images that make
you know sense to you as a human or
are images that you could potentially
generate by going out
with a camera so the data you're
considering
lives on a very low dimensional manifold
in this big space and you have to
explicitly
think about that now the data is
the data manifold here is represented in
this in this sheet in the middle
and on this manifold you're going to
have your different
classes of of data here the blue
or one class and the red are the other
class
what this paper claims is that what
classifiers do what neural networks do
when they classify
the training data here is they go
and they lay their decision boundary
instead of so in the old model you would
have thought
maybe something like this happened where
you put your decision boundary
sort of in the middle between the two
classes right crossing
the manifold right here so you sort of
put it in the middle between the two
classes
and then when you have to
create an adversarial example again what
you would do is you would maybe start
here
what you have to do is you would go
straight towards the decision boundary
right here
okay crossing the decision boundary and
then on the other side you'd have
an adversarial example
in this new model what they claim is the
decision boundary actually doesn't look
like
this right here okay the decision
boundary
actually is very much aligned
with the manifold of data as you can see
right here so this
mesh that they show is the decision
boundary now
and their claim is that that usually
just aligns
with the manifold of data however um
around the actual data around the
training samples
what the classifier will do is it will
create these what
these dimples okay and these dimples are
just tiny well dimples tiny
perturbations in the decision manifold
such that
the data is on the correct side of the
decision manifold
sorry of the decision boundary right so
the blue
points here are under or one side of the
decision boundary and the red points are
on the other side of the decision
boundary
and for the rest the decision boundary
just aligns with
the data the data manifold
now if you want to make an adversarial
example now
what you have to do again you start from
an image
and again you walk straight towards the
decision boundary
however now you don't have to go um
like this you so what you can do is you
can go simply perpendicular to the data
manifold
and you will cross the decision boundary
very quickly because the dimple you're
in is is kind of shallow and they give a
reason why the dimples are
shallow because they claim this is um
results from training these models
and that explains some things so the
difference
is the difference is we started out from
this
to make an adversarial example we have
to go towards the decision
boundary okay if we sort of transfer
this image into
higher dimensions it looks like this in
the middle
again in order to make an adversarial
example we have to go towards the
decision
boundary now in the old mental image
going perpendicular to the decision
boundary means
walking on the data manifold because we
walk
from this group of data towards this
group of data
okay you can see right here that we're
walking on the data manifold
when we walk perpendicular to the
decision boundary whereas in the new
model
walking perpendicular to the decision
boundary
coincides with also walking
perpendicular
to the data manifold so this is the
the difference right here that they
that they claim so
this they say there's um we call this
conceptual framework
the dimpled manifold model and note that
it makes
three testable claims about the kinds of
decision boundaries created by trained
deep neural networks
first natural images are located in a
k-dimensional manifold where k
is much smaller than n second
deep neural network decision boundaries
pass very close to this image manifold
and third the gradient of the
classification's
confidence level has a large norm
and points roughly perpendicular to the
image
manifold all right so these are
these are the claims that they're going
to make to be
tested and to be supported by
experiments i guess
so i hope i've represented enough what
the authors claim right here
i hope they would agree that i've
represented this this accurately
so now where is the problem with this in
my opinion
the problem isn't necessarily with what
they claim right here
um it's it's you know i don't
necessarily disagree with this mental
image
i don't necessarily disagree with these
claims in fact
that the data is on low dimensional
manifold this we've
this is kind of commonly agreed upon
assumption
right as i said not all the
possible pixels uh combinations make
good natural images and that the fact
that it is
then a manifold is a commonly
held assumption decision boundaries pass
very close to the image manifold well
the fact
that we can generate adversarial
examples right
already means that decision boundaries
pass very close to the image manifold
so this also is not news this this has
been
like in everybody's conceptual framework
for
the last five years at least
and then third the gradient of the
classification's confidence level has a
large norm
and points roughly perpendicular to the
image
manifold and this claim right here i'm
pretty
pretty sure there so this is not
a trivial claim um
which yes okay this is not something
that was
like said around much however
i'm going to claim that their model
is not the only model by far that makes
this happen or any something like this
specifically when we go look at the
experiments i'm going to show
you that um this doesn't necessarily
support their claims
it doesn't disprove them right but it
also doesn't necessarily
support them just because they show that
okay
so the other problem i have with this is
that this
this thing they build up as ooh this is
this is the old mental image this is how
people
thought about adversarial examples until
now i look i jus i disagree like this
it's a bit of a it's a bit of a straw
man
almost i feel like this no one
no one thought no one that is sort of
in the literature of adversarial
examples thought or
thinks that this is an appropriate model
for what is happening
like we know that these distances here
are very small right the distance until
you cross the decision boundary
and we know also like if this were true
you should just be able to go to the
decision boundary and then go
the same distance right and then at some
point you would actually arrive
at a sample of a different class so you
could you could actually
transform images into the other class by
simply
going into the adversarial direction
which is precisely what we don't see
right we see the image still largely
looks the same
what gets added looks like a bit of
noise okay so no
no one was having this mental image
because clearly
this mental image is is not appropriate
for adversarial examples
as well as saying look if you think of
this in sort of higher dimensions
um and i realize i've drawn this
decision boundary but this is what they
describe
in the text um then
i i don't i don't see that this is the
correct way
of like there are many different
kinds of decision boundaries that are
compatible with
um with the decision boundary right here
by the way this decision boundary i drew
doesn't even separate the
classes all the classes correctly what
i'm saying is that
also if you consider the decision
boundary that for example looks
like um out of colors looks like
this that also crosses here however
it's sort of kind of flat
like this but it's still a linear
decision boundary
right um like this okay
so this is above and the other part is
below
if you think of this if you project this
down it looks
the same in 2d and in 3d
it also explains that decision
boundaries are very
close to the data samples it's
a bit different though than this dimpled
manifold hypothesis right
if you i think the at least in my
estimation
what's happening is much more that you
have just a bunch of these
kind of linear uh decision boundaries
flying around right here partitioning up
the space and so
on and this might result in a similar
situation as here
but it has quite different predictions
in form of what it does
than what it does right here here it's
sort of a
flat manifold dimpling around the data
whereas here it's kind of the classifier
separating the space into many
regions always trying to sort of
distinguish one class from the other
and yeah so might
end up bit the same but i don't think
they give
a fair shot at what we know so far
like we that this model is not
a a model that people hold in general
especially the one on the left
i can make an attempt at making a mental
model
that people hold so far maybe it's just
me
but i have a feeling this is a bit more
so the model uh that i call let's call
it something
because they call there something right
i call mine the
squishy the stretchy feature model okay
let's contrast this with the stretchy
feature model
so what i want to do is i have two
features and this is a coordinate system
in feature space okay so there's two
features this in feature space i mean
sort of the
the last representation before the
classification layer
in feature space the two classes look
like this
so there is the red class
and there is the blue class and you can
see right here there are
two features and for some reason the
network
can classify along these two features
maybe because there are other classes
other data points so we can't put a
decision boundary like this
between the two we can classify along
the two features
okay so you can see there are two
features right here feature one
and feature two and both features are
actually
pretty good features for keeping these
two data points apart
okay now there are empty spaces as you
can see
right here uh which we're gonna get to
in a second
but you can you can use both features
and ideally a classifier would actually
use both features it would say you know
if feature one is high
it's there probably a red class if
feature two is low it's probably the red
class
and the combination makes even more of
the red class
however since we are in a deep neural
network
which is has transformations it
transforms the data along the way
if you look at the same situation in
input space so in the actual pixel space
it looks different and this is due to
not necessarily the non-linearity of
things but actually
it is due to the the linear
transformation
it's actually the problem of adversarial
examples at least in my estimation
appears to happen in the linear layers
if you think of
for example like eigenvectors of
matrices and
the largest eigenvalues determine how
far you can go in a particular direction
by having a sort of a standard input
delta and the same happens here by the
way this is why spectral norm
regularization tends to work
at least a little bit against
adversarial examples so what i mean is
if you look at the scale of these
features right they are like
one two three four five of these
features one two three four
five if you look in the input space some
of the features
are going to have roughly the same scale
right here
and these features are going to be
features that
you have to change the input a lot in
order to change the feature a lot
what do i mean by this this is something
like the shape
of an of an image okay if you think of a
cat
uh the general shape of a cat
you know it has it has two ears pointy
it has a head
and and so on that's the general shape
of a cat
um sorry that is actually the left right
feature right this is the
the left right feature is the shape
and i have to change the input a lot in
order to affect the feature
right so they're roughly on the same
scale of what i have to change to change
the feature
however the other the other feature
in the input space has a much different
scale
than it has on in the feature space
and this might be something like the fur
structure of a cat
so the first structure of a cat like is
i can change the pixels a tiny bit and
i'm going to change the first structure
by a lot i can change the first
structure of a cat to the first
structure of a dog by just changing uh
the by just changing the pixels a little
however it will be different and now it
will be the first structure of a dog
so how does this change now in
input space in input space it's going to
look something
like this where one feature dimension is
going to look
rather the same and the other feature
direction is going to be
very very stretched okay
now remember both of these features are
good features
they both can be used to classify the
images
so you can see changing the shape
requires a lot of pixels changing the
first structure however requires just a
little pixel
now if i take some image
and i draw an l2 ball around it which is
what we usually do when we create an
adversarial example we say
only we only allow small to
perturbations
you can see that in in this direction
it's a very you know you don't get very
far in feature space
but if you go the same distance in
the in the input space into this
direction
in the feature space you're going to
walk
a lot you're going to walk like way far
and this is just by definition there are
going to be
many features that you can use to
classify images and they're going to be
good features they're not going to be
errors or aberrations like the first
structure is a good feature to classify
a cat
they're going to be many features in
there and some
of them are going to be of large
magnitude and some of them are going to
be of small magnitude
and this is just what happens okay
so i call this the the the stretchy
feature model and this
is sort of a direct result of this paper
that they cite by
alexander madrid's group which we're
going to get to in a second
all right but keep those two in mind and
we're going to see
how which one explains the phenomena
better
and which one doesn't okay
so they say why
deep neural networks are likely to
create dimpled manifolds as decision
boundaries and the the idea here
is that okay we have to now explain
why this even happens so if you consider
the data manifold in green right here
and here we have just one dimensional
data and you can see
it's not linearly separable right so we
have to have sort of a
curve decision boundary around this
um and why would this result in a
dimpled manifold
so they say look if you
start off your your deep neural network
training your maybe your decision
boundary is going to be
somewhere like here okay not very
effective
what's going to happen is let's say what
you want
what you want is you want to have the
blue data
you wanna have the blue data above and
the red data below the decision boundary
so right now the red data is is
oh that's the other way around the red
above
and the blue below so right now the blue
are fine like the blue don't complain
you do get a gradient out of the red
examples pushing the entire decision
boundary down there's no resistance
right the blue ones they're they're fine
so you're gonna push down this is your
next decision boundary
okay same situation you're gonna push
the entire decision boundary down
now you're here now you're too far so
you're gonna push the entire decision
boundary up because now the red ones are
fine the blue ones complain
and this results you being sort of right
on top of the data
four once okay and then both gradients
kick in so now
the red data are gonna
push such the decision boundary down the
blue data are going to push the decision
boundary up
which is going to result in this
sort of dimples
around the data otherwise the decision
boundary coinciding
with the data okay this is their
explanation for
why the this why this works
i hope this makes a little bit of sense
now
um yeah so they claim that that this
is happening uh contrast this with the
mental model of having a bunch of linear
half spaces which would result in
something like you know a decision
boundary being
through here a decision boundary being
through here
and through here through here um
which would also explain what we see but
this
is their claim why this decision
boundary looks
the way it is to me
it's um it's a bit it's a bit weird
right like
here why should the decision boundary
align with the data manifold
maybe it doesn't maybe they don't they
don't claim that i should not
complain about this but for example
in between the data why does it do that
they give some
examples right here the decision
boundary it should be
rather simple right it doesn't
like to curve a lot
they say the new model can help to
understand
why the training phase of a given
network typically converges to the same
global optimal
placement of the decision boundary
regardless of its random initialization
they're going to make a claim right here
why this happens to demonstrate this
point consider the old model
in which you sprinkle at random
locations in the two-dimensional square
alert
as the large number of classes uh
depicted in figure three
sorry um i was confused for a second
i am no longer so they're talking about
this figure right here
they say look in the old model
you have if you want to pass sort of
simple decision boundaries through this
um you have to sort of pass them
like some of the gray ones we see right
here and
they are not going to be so good okay so
our goal is to pass a decision boundary
of bounded complexity
and this bounded complexity comes up
again and again they claim of course
their decision boundary is very smooth
and very simple
which will best separate the red and
blue clusters
they say there is a large number of way
to do ways to do this like the green
lines
and most of them will be about equally
bad in particular any decision
to pass one side or the other of some
cluster can make it harder to
accommodate
other clusters elsewhere along the line
consequently there will likely be many
local minima of roughly the same quality
in the dimpled manifold model however
there is likely to be a single globally
best decision boundary
shape since there is no conflict between
our ability to go above one cluster
and below a different cluster when they
do not intersect
so their idea here is that rather
putting the decision boundaries like
this
what they want to do is you look at this
in three dimensions
and then they just kind of put a sheet
over top of it and
above the blue ones and they're below
the red
ones in all of the three dimensions
right so
you go above the blue ones and below the
red ones
rather than this these gray things like
here which are
not very optimal now
this one i'm not really sure what to
make of this because
first of all uh they say it typically
converges to the same
global optimal placement of the decision
boundary regardless of random
initialization we we know that this is
not true
right um i've specifically made videos
on research by
stanislaw ford who shows that
if you randomly initialize a network
differently
what will happen is you will reach the
same accuracy
but it will it will make mistakes on
different
samples of the test set right and
there's actually a structure
to how these decision boundaries are
going to be different
depending on your random initialization
which actually would support what they
claim is the old view right here
second of all i have no trouble making a
decision boundary here that separates
red
and blue right i can go something like
this like this
come here okay you get here
right i have no trouble separating red
and blue i guess this should go
here um so there this this
kind of this kind of bounded complexity
does a lot of work here them saying oh
the decision boundary should be simple
and so on
and that's why they insist
that these decision boundaries should be
somehow straight
but then a lot but i disagree that their
decision boundaries are so simple
if you have to curve around every data
sample and otherwise
follow the image manifold like that
seems to be like a
rather complex decision boundary
honestly
um because it's it's it's kind of a
generative model of the data
right if you follow the the data
manifold
so i i disagree that theirs
is so much simpler right just because it
doesn't bend
that much and here it like bends a lot
that's also something they say like you
you don't want to bend decision boundary
so much that hardens training
and third of all why do they give
their model the benefit of the third
dimension
right so they claim like oh look the old
model doesn't work
because if you have to place division
boundary between the data points
um you're going to end up with a bad
decision boundary
however in order for their model to work
they need the third dimension they need
to pass like
under and over the data in the third
dimension
whereas if you actually go into the
third dimension
you know every single lecture you have
on kernelized svms and whatnot
they show you like if you go in higher
dimensions these things are actually
separable like you would make
if you have like rbf kernels these would
become a cluster these would become a
cluster and so on this is
sort of the first lecture on
going into higher dimensions in order to
linearly classify stuff
so it's not like their method can
explain anything
more than any other method if you give
it this
third dimension and the fact that they
don't give the old model the third
dimension but they give themselves the
third dimension in order to explain it
is a little bit i'm not i don't know
it's like me um
yeah so i i don't think this is any
argument
for for their model it just simply shows
that if
you have a lower dimensional manifold of
data
and you classify it in a higher
dimension there are ways
to do that right and if you like if you
have relu networks and linear
classifiers
it's going to look like more chunky it's
going to kind of divide the space
into these kind of relu cells where you
classify the data
all of this is compatible with what
they're saying
not just their dimpled manifold
hypothesis
all right so this is yeah i don't i
don't see the big explanation here
so they claim what can they explain with
their model
explaining the mysteries of adversarial
examples
okay there are five things they claim
they can explain
with this first of all the mixture
mystery
right how can it be that a tiny distance
away from any cat image
there is also an image of a guacamole
and vice versa
um okay if these and if these classes
are intertwined in such a fractal way
how can a neural network correctly
distinguish between them
our answer is that all the real cat and
guacamole images reside in
on the tiny image manifold but below the
real cut images there is a whole half
space of pseudo guacamole images
which are not natural images of
guacamole and above the guacamole images
there is a whole half space of
pseudo cat images so their idea here is
that okay you have this one dimensional
data manifold
here are the cats here the guacamoles if
you have your dimpled
manifold curving sort of around the data
right here
uh you know all of this is technically
guacamole
so if you go from the cat to here you
reach
a non-natural guacamole image just by
the fact
so the explanation here is that um
the explanation is that this this
the decision boundary lines up with the
data manifold
except around the data where it creates
a small dimple
and therefore you can cross the dimple
into the other
region okay you this is very
it's the same effect as this model right
here
you know i can draw this dimpled
manifold i can draw it right here right
if i classify
the image i can draw this dimpled
manifold i get the same effect however
this model here
explains much more it actually
explained like here there is no reason
if you think about a multi-class setting
right if you think of
this in two classes fine but if you
think of this in a multi-class setting
there is no reason why this region right
here
should be guacamole it can be any other
class right if the
if the idea is the decision boundary
follows the data manifold
and then just dimples around the data to
make the data
correct declassify the only constraint
here is
is that these are cats it says nothing
about sorry it says nothing
about y on the other side there is
guacamole instead
of anything else and that does not
coincide with what we know about
adversarial examples
like this region here is a consistent
region
what so first of all first of all my
bigger problem is why does this
even generalize why does the dimpled
manifold hypothesis even generalize
right
like if it follows the if it follows the
data manifold
largely except around the the training
data
um why does it exactly generalize well
to test
data you have to like argue that the
test data is here quite close
because otherwise it would be it would
get very confused
on test data which would be somewhere
else on the manifold right
so but we know that generally neural
networks classify data that's on the
manifold of natural images
quite well they generalize quite well
um however this model is sort of an
anti-generalization model but okay maybe
you can claim that
their test images are close enough to
the training images such that this works
but for example we know
that if that um
this this is a consistent region what do
i mean by this
we know for example we can make
universal adversarial perturbations
which means that we can find directions
that no matter from which image or from
which class we start from they will
always result
in guacamole this is not explained by
the dimpled manifold there is no reason
why these regions on the other side
should be of a consistent
label in a multi-class setting we also
know
that adversarial perturbations are
transferable which means that we can
make an adversarial perturbation in one
um classifier and then in a different
classifier even if it's trained with a
different data set actually
we can we can apply the same adversarial
perturbation and it will most likely
still
be of the same like the adversarial
perturbation going towards the same
class there is no reason
in the dimpled manifold hypothesis that
explains these phenomena
if you think of this of the stretchy
feature model
this is real easy right if i create an
adversarial example
um i go across the decision boundary
right here
what do i do i change the fur without
changing the shape
now i change the fur by so much that
you know now there is a conflict right
in feature space i go up here
now there is a conflict it has the fur
of a dog
but the shape of a cat still
now i there is a conflict but neural
networks in the final layer are linear
which means they just weigh the
different features now i just
pump that fur to be so dog-ish right
that it
overpowers the shape feature of the cat
neural networks are
biased towards sort of structure anyway
over
shape already so i just i just hammer
that fur
and now the neural network thinks it's
it's a dog
and a different neural network trained
on the same data will also think it's a
dog because it will also
have learned to classify images by shape
and
fur therefore um therefore
it will it will be vulnerable to the
same attack right
this is super easy to explain in this
model there is no reason why this should
happen in the dimpled manifold model
unless you amend it by some more
hand-wavy
things they say the direction
mystery when we use an adversarial
attack to modify a cat into guacamole
why doesn't the perturbation look green
and mushy
okay so they say well
in the old model you would have to walk
along the image
manifold from here towards the guacamole
images
and that should mean that your image
should sort of change to look like a
guacamole
in our mo in the dimple manifold model
you go off the manifold perpendicular
and that explains why the adversarial
perturbation looks like
a little bit like just random noise
again no one thought this
in the old model in fact we have a
pretty good explanation why it still
looks the same
and that's because humans are much more
receptive to this thing right here to
the shape
whereas neural networks also or much
more consider
this thing right here the fur so they
consider fur
and shape in different proportions than
the humans
uh do and so
that's we already sort of knew this
and it's in fact a better explanation um
the uniformity mystery you know why the
decision boundary
is ever present um so they claim because
the
there's this dimple right here even you
know the most far away
cat image here has a close crossing to
the decision boundary
so there is no cat images that are kind
of closer to the decision boundary but
this is i think this is just a property
of a high dimensional classifier i think
that
here our 2d view of the world betrays
us and um yeah especially if we can go
really far in feature space
with a tiny perturbation and input space
this is not
not a mystery not even a mystery the
vanishing
gap mystery um okay which is about
adversarially
training i i think uh which we're
gonna skip here and then there is the
accuracy
robustness trade-off mystery
so this is if you do if you train a
model adversarially
which means that here look here i have
my cat okay i train i have a data set of
cats and dogs
i train my neural network on it it's
vulnerable what can i do
what i can do is i can create
adversarial images this is a cat right i
can create adversarial images
by making this into a dog
okay so this is a dog because i changed
the first structure a little bit
this is an adversarial example now i add
this so this is comes from the data set
now i add this to the data set but i
tell it this is a cat
too right this is a cat and this is a
cat
if i do this with my neural network the
neural network will become
robust to adversarial examples to a
degree
not fully but to a degree this is the
best method we have so far
of defending against adversarial
examples called adversarial training
now what you do when you do this
is you train the network to to sort of
classify
the yeah classify to incorporate the
adversarialness
into its decision making process and
this results usually in a degradation
of the generalization performance of the
network so as it becomes more
robust it becomes less accurate on
real data right you gain accuracy on
adversarial data
you decrease the accuracy in real data
which
makes sense intuitively but it is a
strong effect
which is not the same as you know i
simply teach my model to do
yet another class um it is quite it is
actually a
a trade-off now they try to explain this
um right here when we train a network we
keep the images stationary and move to
decision boundary
by creating dimples when we create
adversarial examples we keep the
decision boundary stationary and move
the images to the other side
by allowing a large perpendicular
derivative
we make the training easier since we do
not have to sharply bend decision
boundary against
around the training examples so this is
when you
train normally when you train without
adversarial examples
they say there is a large perpendicular
derivative
which um in the like the
what they mean is that the data samples
sort of push
these dimples out that that's the large
perpendicular
derivative the perpendicularity is to
the image manifold
and that makes it easy because you don't
have to bend
the decision boundary a lot so you can
kind of remain here
and you have to kind of create these
dimples again their argument is you
don't want to bend this boundary
a lot which makes training easy
um however such a large derivative also
creates very close adversarial examples
yeah this is their claim that now the
decision boundary
is pretty close because you don't bend
the decision boundary by too much around
the data because you do dimples
any attempts to robustify a network by
limiting
all its directional derivatives will
make the network harder to train and
thus less accurate
i'm not super sure how to interpret this
so i might be
doing this wrong right here but if you
create adversarial example what you do
is you
essentially have this data point and you
create an adversarial example this
statement is
a well these are of the same class so
now that this now the
the decision boundary has to sort of
bend
harder okay which makes it uh more
hard to train and at some point it
so it's harder to train and that's why
you have less accuracy and at some point
it says well
actually i don't want to bend that much
i'd rather make a mistake here
and just bend around both of these data
points and now you have
a wrong classification so
that's sort of their explanation of why
this happens which i find
a bit hand wave you have to argue like
ease of training
bending the decision boundary and so on
in this model right here
super easy okay what happens if i create
cats that have cat fur and doctor and i
tell the network these both are cats
well essentially i tell them i tell the
network look there are two features
right here
the fur and the cat and you know the fur
just just disregard it just don't do
that
don't regard the fur as a feature
because
it's useless now because i now have cats
with cat fur and cat with dog fur so the
network
can't use that to classify anymore and
that explains why it gets less accurate
because i take away
one useful feature okay so you know now
the network has less
useful features and that's why it gets
worse
this it's it's a pretty simple
explanation
in the stretchy feature model it has
there's a lot of work to make this
happen in the
dimpled manifold model so lastly they
try to explain
and they became an interesting mystery
um in this this paper that i have cited
throughout and what that is is that it's
kind of the same experiment as
here where we create adversarial
examples and we add them to the training
set
except for two things first of all
we don't have the original so our new
data set
is not going to contain the original
images
it's only going to contain the
adversarial examples
second it is going to
contain the adversarial example image
but the label isn't going to be the
correct label quote-unquote correct
from where we created but the label is
actually going to be
the adversarial label the wrong label
okay
so we're going to tell the network this
is a dog
please learn that this is a dog right
it's a cat with dog fur
and the old training images are nowhere
in the data set we just do a data set
with these wrongly
labeled images now when we go
and we apply this so we train we use
this we train a network right to
classify cats and dogs
and now we once we've trained this
network we go we take one of these
samples of the original data set
we classify it it's going to give us a
correct
classification right so it will
recognize that this here
is a cat even though we told it that
this here
is a dog now how does it do this
uh it does this by looking at the fur
you know we've
we've doubled down on the fur here right
so this is like we we really made that
fur
feature super strong in these
adversarial examples so it's going to
look at the cat fur
and even though none of the cats had the
shape like this
we sort of we sort of supercharged that
fur feature
again in this model not a problem
essentially what we've done is we've
created
two data classes you know one up here
and one down here that have the first
supercharged
and now it's just going to mainly look
at that first structure
and that is a useful feature right so
this
this what's called the features not bugs
paper
adversarial examples are features not
bugs or
other way around not bugs they are
features um
has demonstrated with this experiment
this notion that there
are adversarial examples result from
useful
generalizing features in the data set
that are simply of by definition the
features that are not
large enough for humans to see what they
call non-robust features
how do they explain this
they say the original people tried to
explain this highly surprising role
by distinguishing between robust and
non-robust features in any given image
where some of them are preserved by the
adversarial change and some are not
however it is not clear what makes some
of the features more robust than
others definition just definition like
like if you have features and you order
them by their
size like by their how much you have to
change the pixels that
some features are going to be larger
than other features
and then some features going to be below
that cutoff where you define adversarial
examples but just this is
definition makes them such that some of
more robust it's not it's not clear
our new model provides a very simple
alternative explanation
which does not necessarily contradict
the original one okay
at least this which is summarized in
figure 4.
to simplify the description we will use
2d vertical cut
through the input space and consider
only the decision boundary that
separates between
cats and anything else okay so
they have this example right here they
say look
we have a decision boundary that
distinguishes cats
see from non-cats and the green one here
is the image manifold
and the gray is the decision boundary
okay
so now what we do is we create
adversarial examples in frame two right
here
you can see we make the cuts into
non-cuts and we make the b
the bats into bats aren't very popular
lately
the badgers into into cats so we make
the badgers into cats
and we make the cats into the
whatever d as ducks okay and now we
relabel
those and that gives us a new data
manifold so the new data manifold is
this data manifold
right here and we have also new labels
and now they claim the resulting
decision boundary
in figure four as you can see right here
this is the resulting decision boundary
the gray one
it is it is very similar to the decision
boundary in the first frame
and therefore we shouldn't be surprised
that this
new decision boundary that results from
this perturbed data
results in the same decision boundary as
the original
one okay however
um like why
like why so their whole
they have two notions notion one is that
the decision boundary
follows the data manifold closely except
it sort of bends around the data a
little and you can see this right here
like this decision boundary kind of
follows the data
yet it just happens to be on the correct
side of
the data points um at any given moment
which okay okay however
they also make the claim in different
parts of their paper that
bending the decision boundary and so on
is not good you'd rather want to have a
simple decision boundary so
to me there's no reason why the decision
boundary couldn't just look like this
it would correctly classify this new
data set
right however it would not correctly
classify um it would not correctly
classify
the let's say the c that was
right where was it right here or right
here
these data points would not correctly
classify so you see that
this until now they've always had this
data manifold to be sort of super duper
straight and smooth and that's how they
can also say
well following the data manifold and not
bending too much and so on
those are not in conflict with each
other but now that they are in conflict
with each other you have to give
gonna give up one or the other and
only in one of them do actually does
this experiment here
still make sense in the other one it
doesn't and
but if you give up the oh bending too
much is bad
then you know you lose a bunch of
explanations that you have
up here so yeah
like it's one in my mind it's one or the
other
and there's there's still no reason i
think no good reason
why this like the decision boundary
should align super closely with
the data points like if there if there
is nothing here
right if this is perpendicular really
to the data manifold like why
would the decision boundary align so
closely with the data manifold in that
point
i don't know
okay so um
they ask why are dnns so sensitive and
humans so
insensitive to adversarial perturbations
essentially
their argument here is that humans
project the input data
onto the image manifold which is a
contested
claim right i don't i don't think that
is a
uh i think that is not not a widely
accepted
i mean it's it's certainly possible uh
but
also i'm not sure i'm not sure that
humans do
project they have like an internal
manifold of natural images and project
onto that
every time they analyze an image and
also
um also the
yeah how do you project right like
how like both of these features are
useful
okay so both of the features are useful
if you project an adversarial example
like why do you project it onto the
shape dimension
and not onto the fur dimension right why
there's no explanation right here we
know that sort of humans are more
receptive to
shapes and so on but just
projecting won't get you there so now
they're going to into
experiments and i want to highlight one
particular experiment
right here they have synthetic
experiments they have other experiments
i want to highlight
this experiment right here remember they
said their experiments were going to
give
you know strong support that um in this
experiment right here
what they want to claim is that okay you
have the data manifold
here if you or if you have a data point
and you make an adversarial example the
question is
um do adversarial examples
go along the image manifold or
do adversarial examples go sort of
perpendicular to the image manifold
they their claim again is that the this
here
would give support to the old view of
adversarial examples
and this here would support the dimpled
manifold view because of course
the decision boundary would be sort of
following the data manifold
curving around the data
and then following the image manifold
again
so here would be sort of the other data
point going below
that a little bit all right so that
is the view right here now
what they're going to try to show you is
that if you want to create an
adversarial example
on the manifold you have to walk much
longer
for much longer until you find an
adversarial example
than if you go off the manifold if you
go
yeah and they're also going to show you
that if you're not constrained
if you can go anywhere you want with an
adversarial example
then that will be very similar to when
you
force the adversarial example to go off
the manifold and this gives a bit of
proof
that you know if two things behave
equally they're you know probably equal
so what they're going to do is they're
going to try to
make an adversarial attack first of all
a regular one
this one you're gonna say okay we're
gonna make an adversarial attack let's
measure
how far we have to go to cross the
decision boundary
second they're going to say let's make
the same thing but let's
force the attack to be on the manifold
of natural images and let's measure
that and lastly they're going to mask
okay let's do the same thing but force
it to be
off the data manifold and then they're
going to measure
how long these are how long the
adversarial attacks are
what's their their norm and they're
going to find
of course they're going to want to find
that these two are about
similar norms and way smaller
than the one that is on the data
manifold sort of giving evidence
to you know if you go perpendicular to
the data manifold you have to go
very not very far and that's what
adversarial attacks do
okay uh yeah so how first of all how do
they
force the the adversarial attack to be
on
the manifold um what they do is they
do an auto encoder so they train an auto
encoder so they
an autoencoder is a neural network that
has sort of a bottleneck layer
and you try to just reconstruct the
input data okay you tried that these two
are equal
however in the middle here you have a
very low dimensional representation so
where this is an
n dimensional representation this is a k
dimensional representation and
a k much smaller than n
if you can reconstruct the images
correctly
that means that you sort of have
captured the representation
in these low dimensions right here so
what they're going to do is they train
an auto encoder
they take that low dimensional
representation they linearize around it
and that's how they have a way to
project
onto the image manifold by simply only
moving around
in this low dimensional manifold right
here or always
projecting onto it first of all it's a
bit of a trouble because
how you train the autoencoder is like
for these experiments i think it's very
relevant to
how the this image manifold is going to
look like if you train it with
l2 you sort of already make some claims
about
what are important features and what not
but let's disregard this
right here let's say they have an
accurate way of projecting onto the
image
manifold onto the manifold of
natural data and here's what they find
look let's look at imagenet okay no
constraint pgd
it this is the norm you know it's some
number okay so like 0.14
now off manifold pgd is where they
deliberately project
off the manifold so they project on the
manifold they subtract that they say
you're not to do anything with the mana
the image manifold
and that's 0.152 which is
slightly larger than the no constraint
pgd
but essentially the same size now on
manifold pgd
okay here is a way bigger number like
six
times bigger number so their claim is
look up
up to six times uh more you have to go
on the manifold than off the manifold
and that gives
credence to their claims
now okay so what i've done is they have
you know they have some descriptions of
their experiment specifically
they have descriptions of what library
they use they used adword torch
okay so i used advertorch2 uh they used
you know l2 pgd i used that too and they
told me how much
their low dimensional representation is
so the k here
how much that is how much the n is
and so i was able to reproduce that
experiment
now what i've done is
i have done the same thing and you can
see right here this is this the panda
image from imagenet they used an
imagenet classifier
and what they do is they do it greedy so
they stop as soon as they cross the
decision boundary and then they
measure the norm you can see right here
this is the perturbation now it's a
soccer ball
and here is the size 0.7772
that's the norm of the original
perturbation
adversarial what i now do is i project
onto
the manifold but i don't the difference
is i don't project onto the image
manifold
what i do is here you see project on 2k
i simply project onto
any k-dimensional manifold so i know
what k
is k is 3 500. um so it's a very small
number compared
to the input number and so what they
project is actually the gradient so the
gradient of the adversarial attack that
you use to update your image
that's what they project they have the
algorithm clearly lined out
so what i do is i simply take you can
see right here
i take a random set
of of dimensions like of of pixel
coordinates
in the gradient and i denote the first
you know the first few the first k as
the manifold
and the last k as not the manifold this
is not the image manifold there's
nothing to do with the image manifold
this is simply
a random k-dimensional subspace
of the pixel space okay and now when i
project
onto k i simply take all the others
in the gradient and i set them to zero
that's
i project onto a k-dimensional manifold
after that you normalize the gradient
and so on so um you proceed you proceed
as you would
right so here you can see the the
project
is used before you normalize the
gradient so there's no
issue with sort of the the step size you
simply project onto the manifold
and i have the same thing by the way
projecting
off the manifold where i simply take the
the k diamond
dimensions and set them to zero okay so
now let's look
what happens if i project onto the
manifold
oh wow before it was 0.77 and now
it's 6.5 so about 8
times larger and now let's look what
happens if i project
off the manifold it's 0.7773
instead of 0.7772 so
what they're seeing right here and you
know maybe okay maybe i've done it
modulo i've done it wrong and i
completely don't understand what's
going on um what they have found is
simply an effect of projecting onto any
lower dimensional space yet they claim
that this
is like in support of their hypothesis
which clearly
i have no clue what the day to manifold
is i've just projected onto a random
manifold
and i got the same results um
so i see they have other experiments
where they try to kind of convince you
with
all the types of perturbations and so on
but
you know like no this these they have
other experiments but
this is just one that i could try
quickly again
maybe i've done it wrong to me this
occam's razor is strong here like
occam's razor in this work is
quite a bit like there can be
like there can be many hypotheses that
coincide
with the results you're getting and with
the phenomena
and it's easy to to think that stuff is
in
favor of your hypothesis is providing
support for it
um when there are other explanations
available
oh i almost forgot about uh goodfellow's
claim
that you know they say belongs to the
sort of old
thinking that is now that is not
a correct thinking and the claim that
when you make an adversarial example you
somehow go towards the centroid of a
different class and
this in imagination it's something like
this on the
on the left right here however if you
think about this
in this space okay let's say you start
out
here and you go towards the centroid
of the other class right the pro like
where's the center right here
approximately like this
what happens in feature space because of
the stretchy feature because of the
different scales
okay what happens in feature space is it
pretty much like the blue arrow
here so it's that in feature space you
go a long way
actually this is probably i should have
drawn
this here to be square and this here to
be super stretchy
right yeah yeah i think so
yeah i was i was wrong in drawing this
so this here should be squares and this
here actually should be
super duper stretchy right so the
centroid what was the centroid here
is like way up here like way up here
somewhere
okay so this gets super stretched and
you cross
the boundary in this one feature right
like the fur feature and um
yeah so i think this is it's still a
correct claim you go towards the
centroid
of another class but because you go this
in input space
um in the feature space this results in
sort of a dramatic shift in some
features
and a not so dramatic shift in other
features so while
in the input space you go towards the
centroid
equally in all pixel directions you
don't go towards the centroid
equally in all pixel directions in the
sorry in all feature directions
so i think the claim the good fellow
made is
valid here still and explains like is
concurrent with the stretchy feature
explanation i'm pretty sure that's also
kind of what
maybe i can't read his mind but maybe
what he meant by that
and not necessarily this picture right
here not necessarily
that actually the entire picture is
going to change into the other
class okay that was the interjection
and back to the conclusion but as i said
make up your own mind what do you what
do you think of this
um go through the paper they
it's it's a good paper like it's written
it's written well
uh it has a lot of experiments has quite
a lot of
appendix where they give you more
results and so on
and it's not like again it's not like
it's in it's necessarily
incompatible right it's not i don't
disagree with them i just think it's
it's not
as useful as they claim and it's kind of
insufficient
i don't disagree with their their main
claims um
yeah and i think we already kind of knew
a lot of those stuff and our current
mental models are
explaining the things uh maybe
a little a little better
and yeah if you use the the squishy
feature
what do they call it the the stretchy
feature model has a fancy name now
but again this this is not mine this is
just kind of a a uh
bringing together of of what we what i
think we know of about adversarial
examples
uh safe to say there's going to be
something that challenges this
and that's going to be exciting all
right thanks so much for being here
listening and i'll see you next time bye
bye